Thanks to Alchemy for sponsoring this video and making it possible to practice organic chemistry
examples in an effective and playful way. You can follow along with me and we'll try this
question together using the Mechanisms app. The link to download this app is in the description
and this question is part of their Essentials Pack which is free. It's under the third section
of addition. It's number five. If you need a refresher on the general mechanism of hydrohallogenation,
then check out my previous video. Onto our example of an alchemy that is not symmetrical. Step one
is protonation. This is where the electrons in the double bond reach out and grab the hydrogen.
Electrons from this bond now go to the bromine and our bromine is now negatively charged since it
gained electrons. Okay, so where does the hydrogen go? Does it go to this carbon or does it go to
the other carbon? Only one is going to be correct. This is known as being regio selective,
meaning the hydrogen is selective or just picky as to which carbon it attaches to. If we were to
have the hydrogen go to this first carbon, it would be wrong and thankfully the Mechanisms app
can help you avoid that mistake thanks to their hint feature. This carbocation is not the most
stable. Remember that a tertiary carbocation is the most stable and most favorable. Then a secondary
carbocation follows and primary and last is a methyl carbocation. We know a carbocation is tertiary
if there are three carbons attached to the carbocation. Two carbons attached to the carbocation is
secondary. One carbon is primary and no carbons attached to the carbocation would be the methyl.
So in this case, our tertiary carbocation is the most stable so the hydrogen would favor the
least substituted carbon. Now that we have the correct carbocation, step two is to have our nucleophile
which is bromine attack the carbocation to form our product. If you notice the hydrogen went to the
least substituted carbon and the halogen went to the most substituted carbon. This is Mark
Kovnikov's rule. Another way to remember this is we always want the most stable carbocation.
So first, make sure to get the most stable carbocation. So a tertiary carbocation if possible. Then do a
nucleophilic attack to form our product which in this case was a tertiary alkyl bromide. Do this
next question on your own using the Mechanisms app. There are hints to help you avoid mistakes and in
the Essentials pack, there's even a video to guide you step by step. The link to download this
app is in the description and to find this exact question, click on the Essentials pack, then it's
the third topic under addition and it's number eight. I'll see you in the next video where we'll
cover when to use a high dried and alkyl shift.